remember what I had over here was all
this fraction business which is what
I've got here again how do I get rid of
the fractions here see how I went from
here to here mmm no more fractions how'd
I do it I had to multiply a bit two
times by the lowest common multiple of
two and three okay so this time I want
the lowest common multiple of seven and
eight now just so happens
that's quite a marginal bomb the gloves
come off on three right is 56 56 course
that's a big number
well it's just it makes the numbers B
but I'll show you a trick I'll show you
a trick
okay so 56 random the way I got 56 was
it was seven times eight is that okay
just have a look at this guy for a
second I can write him in two different
ways okay if I divide both sides here by
seven right to my list my center you get
a okay
or I could divide both sides by eight
okay now I'm gonna take advantage of
these two up here watch okay if I
multiply both of these guys by 56 56 you
think the numbers are gonna get huge
they are gonna get bigger but not
unmanageably bigger should have kept
around 5 56 times this and 56 times this
okay
now I couldn't go 56 times 256 times 3
and the numbers will start to get huge
admit I can cancel later on ah
but instead I'm gonna look at these guys
right because they're going to help me
56 over 7 right there 56 over 7 I know
he's going to be equal to 8 so I'll have
8 times 2
okay can you see what happened there the
56 over seven
that's what became days we established
that yeah I'm multiplying everything by
56 why am i doing that it's the lowest
called multiple when I do it it'll get
rid of all these parts fractions okay
that's why I'm doing it okay
so that's why multiply that by 56 and
that's why 56 so if you didn't notice if
you do something to the left hand side
you do to the right hand side
ah but it's zero yeah 56 times 0 is
still 0 so that's really cool yeah the
whole lot everything okay but 56 right
the reason why I chose it is because
it'll cancel this 7 I don't cancel this
a the way we'll do it is like this okay
so that's why 56 over 7 becomes a and 56
over a is going to become 7 right
okay all right let me just show you
again see it's fifty six hundred seven
fifty six over a seven I'm trying to
hear it a fractions that's what I'm
trying to do because multiply my 56
right the reason why I chose it is
because specifically because it would
cancel with the seven right and with the
eight that's why I chose the lowest
common multiple okay so that's why now
you can look at this slide all the
fractions are gone which is what I was
after in the first place okay okay
eight times two what take those two
sixteen seven times three okay and thank
you for the okay and now at this point I
have gotten rid of all the fractions and
it's just like before
I can't expand and collect the like
terms let's do it 16 times X now Peter
66 plus 16 times 165 21 21 times 2x well
done now watch out for the negative
there 21 times negative 5 that's a big
number as well give me tip 5 times 20 is
100 105 42 X Y a point to else now the
dump is a lot but that's okay we can do
it now we click like terms EXO let's do
that okay well done
don't stop okay Tom click like toast the
exes
well done okay kid this is somewhat 1605
I'm getting that of course what do I do
now I could either divine or I could
yeah I would do that first problem well
by it I could divide it first if I watch
it but if I didn't do my first thoughts
right now there you go and I'm dying
with it so bingo